[Música]
essa história que eu vou contar começou
há 50 anos atrás da noruega
um dia eu andei lá boleia com uma
mochila nas costas e um dia passei por
uma pequena cidade chamada eva os 140
quilômetros a nordeste gaúcho
à noite procurava um sítio pro do milan
e encontrei na floresta você era de
campanhas e uma delas estava aberto e
muito acolhedora
então esta lei mas no dia seguinte
acordei com algemas e fiquei detido 24
horas na prisão local por ter dormido no
museu ao livro no famoso museu do
vereador no ano seguinte quando se que
um estágio na colômbia ao longo de 30
semanas
mergulhei entre mil civis rurais e andei
com a peneira do instituto o que eu
muito me marcou e apanhei répteis para a
recém-criada universidade de casa na
manhã hoje esteve inscrito como um aluno
de geologia regresso amanhã comecei a
trabalhar com cobras e depois fiz uma
viagem aquática para apanhar uma
especial na nossa que consegui também
trazer clandestinamente maneira lá
escrevi um estudo sobre o modo da
alimentação de espécies de cobras para
participar num concurso para jovens
cientistas e ganhei o primeiro prémio em
biologia do dinheiro para concretizar
parte de um sonho antigo
em 1985 já estava inscrito como o aluno
de biologia marinha da universidade que
encontrei na costa do mar do norte no
pequeno porte do fluido scocco
uma câmera abandonará a úrsula com 16
metros de cumprimento e construído em
1938 a sua recuperação demorou dois anos
e custou muitas lágrimas
muitos hoje mas era mais lágrimas de
alegria e no fim fizemos uma viagem
inesquecível femininas náuticas da
maneira t da bahia do ps na batalha onde
eu recolhi centenas e centenas de
amostras de moluscos marinhos para a
minha tese de mestrado
um dia ainda durante as aulas na
universidade que o meu professor e
orientador da tese falou do pequeno a
claro abandonado no final foto não fosse
do douro no porto fechado ao público
desde 1967
pensei a recuperação de um aquário é um
trabalho iria pra mim e pra ter dinheiro
e assim tentei arranjar uma bolsa para
portugal e após muitas tentativas
falhadas quando seguia a desejada bossa
e assim que cheguei o porto em outubro
de 1979
tanto a 40 anos o escutarem hoje
encorajaram no para trabalhar no sentido
da via abertura do aquário mas a idéia
caiu em um solo infértil
então consegui uma bolsa de doutoramento
que dediquei ao estuário do rio mínio e
uma das suas particularidades pouco
conhecidas naquela altura estávamos em
a pesca do meixão um disco muito
apreciado pelos canhões e hoje em dia
uma maca dura mercadoria muito preciosa
para o contrabando chinês
em 1982 o instituto de ciências
biomédicas convidou para leccionar
ecologia aquática no recém criado
do curso de ciências do meio aquático
terminei o tratamento em 85 e continue a
trabalhar no instituto a trabalhar sobre
experiências e de crescimento do mission
e aquilo que o tão bem que poucos anos
mais tarde nós uma aluna minha está aqui
hoje presente
conseguimos organizar um congresso
internacional ea não viver na reitoria
da universidade do porto e convidando
vários cientistas então participaram
menos 60 cientistas estrangeiros e ano
todo mundo cantando convidaram para
fazer conferência sobre o meu chão o
famoso os irmãos mexam do rio minho é em
sítios como japão austrália nova
zelândia ea tasmânia china e rom com
tanto nestas viagens em outras praças
duas médicas e para a maior parte dos
países europeus
comecei a colecionar objetos ligados à
pesca artesanal para eventuais montagem
do museu no equipas esta idéia se iria
concretizar mais tarde numa outra forma
em 1984 consegui alugar uma casa em
frente ao mar na famosa praia da aguda a
quinta nova de gaia onde existia uma
pequena frota de 24 barcos da pesca de
sábado no cairo centenas de vezes
acompanhei os pescadores e dezenas de
vezes fiquei mobiliado até os ossos
logo logo de manhã às 5 horas na saída
para o mar agitado com um amigo meu
juntos tiramos milhares de fotografias
para documentar a pesca para fazer um
livro e isso despertou a curiosidade da
câmara municipal de vila nova de gaia
que um dia no perguntou quais seria a
minha ideia sobre o desenvolvimento da
praia da aguda
então sem visitar sem pensar muito
sugere a construção de um aquário museu
junto à praia a outra que concordou com
a idéia e assim nasceu o projeto da
estação litoral da aguda ela entretanto
vendi o meu barco e para recuperar a
casa antiga do buscador
a construção dela começou em 1993 e
custou um milhão e meio de euros
financiado em 75 por cento pela
secretaria de estado do turismo com
dinheiro do cafezinho dos filho a obra
correu muito bem até ao meio da roupa
que o empreiteiro foi à falência mas
mesmo assim continuamos e aí ela
conseguiu abrir as suas portas ao
público no dia 1 de julho 1999
então vamos entrar ela tem um museu das
pescas quando cerca de 2 mil objetos
antigos yuan e inclui duas exposições
permanecem todas as peças esculturas uma
colecção de esculturas em barro sobre
sistemas de pesca e as figuras 140
figuras a piscar a transportar o vento
ea buscar oriundas de 40 países tenham a
claro na fauna e flora aquáticas locais
sobretudo marinhas e han min animais das
60 espécies de uma biodiversidade
fantástica
além disso tem um departamento de
educação e investigação com ligação ao
instituto de ciências biomédicas em 2002
foi concluído a construção do quebra mar
um grande passo importante e nossa um
sony o velho sonho dos pescadores de
terem um porto d'abrigo manifestado pela
primeira vez em 1936
em 2004 ela foi classificada como o
melhor jardins o nosso jogo de portugal
entre 27 e outras instituições à frente
do cenário
e o relatório final
anoto que ela devia servir de exemplo
para os outros então vamos veiculando
agora a 1996 até ao ano ante uma pequena
associação da qual fiz parte a pintura
implantar um aquário na margem
portuguesa do rio mínio naquela altura
lembrei na noruega onde tinha sido preso
há 26 anos atrás então convidamos o
então presidente da câmara de vila nova
de cerveira para visitar os museus têm
inclusive votar museu do lenhador local
do crime
o taka gostou tanto da idéia da viagem e
da ideia cana chegou logo depois um
projeto muito semelhante à ela o ator
museu do rio minho que mostra a arte de
pesca locais e espécies sobretudo peixes
deste ano até a faixa está abriu em 2005
e tem um sucesso enorme
ambos os lados da fronteira no dia 11 de
julho 1999 desculpa 2019 a ela fecha o
seu 20º aniversário esteve sempre a
ganhar todas as dias domingos e feriados
incluídos ea nunca fechou sete mil e
trezentos dias seguintes e atraiu 400
mil visitantes ao longo dos anos
conseguimos montar uma série de
programas pedagógicos
as aulas para todas as classes e idades
de todos os níveis de ensino e desce de
jardins de infância até a universidade
nesse caso o ipas muito frequentadas são
as aulas de pacote não elas vai a sete
dias por semana para animar corpo e alma
nos primeiros lá nossa ela incluiu a 16
tartarugas marinhas e ano arrojados na
praia ou buscadas nas redes da pesca
costeira
essas drogas foram todas recuperadas
marcadas libertados no mar aberto
mas desde 2008 já não apareceu nenhuma o
que ensinar preocupando a investigação
dela em seguida sobre o logo do google
feio num projecto que inclui o cultivo
até agora lançamos 400 vagas por carlos
omar ea taxa de captura e mais ou menos
10% para ver para calcular o crescimento
em meio natural
o cultivo de lavagante e algo
preocupante e difícil resulta difícil
porque eles comem nos outros a o
canibalismo mostrando a outras
modalidades o que obriga de isolar os
animais a de cada um no seu próprio
hotel de cinco estrelas já até terem
tamanho suficiente para poderem ser
lançados ao mar ao longo dos anos
conseguimos publicar uma série de livros
e último guia o novo dia dela teve foi
publicitado inglês e mandarim
foi lançado no dia 11 de julho em
relação ao futuro a ela está envolvida
em dois projetos o primeiro o centro de
mergulho e talassoterapia com uma
piscina com 15 metros de profundidade
que será abastecida com água do mar já
tratada pela estação em soluções tela da
estação litoral da aguda e o segundo
projeto é o pequeno portinho de pesca ea
para incentivar a nova fixação de novas
unidades entre os as gerações mais novas
para esta profissão tão característica
não desaparece completamente da praia da
aguda e lembrando que em 1984
tínhamos vinte e quatro barcos e hoje em
dia restam apenas cinco
enfim cheguei ao fim do meu latim
a história o caminho até ela foi longo e
sinuoso mas construímos acho um projeto
sólido cuja dimensão é garanta um bom
equilíbrio ea entre os quatro vertentes
cultural turístico e científico
pedagógico muito obrigado pela vossa
atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]